everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we're looking at
game 16 from the 1972 World Chess
Championship between Bobby Fischer and
Betty Spassky Fischer's had the upper
hand he has nine points compared to
Buddy spassky's six points who has a
pretty good lead going into Game sixteen
this is the best of 24 so assuming that
Bobby Fischer can hold on a four even
just a few more games if you were to
squeak out a winner - it would be
mathematically impossible but for birdie
Spassky to come back Bobby Fischer does
have the white pieces had a few games as
drawls lately so looking to get back on
the winning side but he's asking knowing
that he needs to make something happen
cannot go down another full point this
late into this series so we're gonna get
started from Bobby Fischer pawn to e4
one of his favorite openings pawn e5
Knight f3 knight c6 Bishop to b5 getting
into the right Lopez and then pawn to a6
and Bobby Fischer decided to go with the
exchange variation one of his favorite
variations in the right Lopez pawn
captures here on d6 now black could
capture here if you wanted to with his
beep on or with his deep on many players
are gonna be capturing with their deep
on one of the few times that you will
see a pawn capture away from this
another board usually pawns are
capturing towards the stern of the board
this also opens up the opportunity for
black to castle on the Queen side and
still have a very strong King defense
Bobby Fischer continues with castling on
the King side you're probably not gonna
see Knight to e5 really a bad move here
because then Queen could come down to d4
attacking both the pawn in the night
here and you know you could protect the
knight with pawn to f4 but you could see
how bad that's gonna be Queen could just
come here to e4 take that would be check
but you can see then I come back here to
have three Queen takes on e4 Queen to e2
and then after the exchange to the King
here on e to black just has a much
better position in this board state so
we're not gonna sing white to do that
and said we see castle
on the kingside there's a few ways if
you look at this from blacks perspective
that they can continue this pawn is
under attack here on e5 so one of the
options that black has is to play pawn
to f6 and usually you don't see this
because it weakens the kingside but as
we talked about Black has the option to
castle on the Queen side so he's not too
worried about his pawn structure on the
King side pushing up a little bit
further another option that he has is
Bishop down here to G for this pins down
the knight so it doesn't have to worry
about the knight coming up here to e5
because then the Queen could fall right
here this is usually followed by pawn to
h3 and then the bishop could come back
here to h5 or black could even play pawn
to h5 and this is similar to if you're
not promote the fishing-pole trap one of
my favorites traps in all of chess if
you haven't watched a video on it you
can go ahead and do that I have created
that for you to watch this is a similar
situation as the fishing pole but it'll
same premise after the the pawn were to
take here the pawn recaptures this opens
up for this rook to have a strong attack
on the King side as we talked about
blacks not too worried about his King
side protection here he's gonna be
castling on the Queen side more than
likely this threatens the knight and
then I can't really defend himself let's
say the knight come down here to e1
Queen down to h4 and this is gonna be
mates in just a matter of moves here so
it puts white in a difficult situation
so even after the pawn comes down here
to h5 White is not just able to capture
here just not how he would like to see
it if we don't see the bishop come down
here to g4 some of the other options
that you could see Queen to d6 trying to
hold on to this pawn or you could even
see bishop here to d6 all of these are
good options as far as how black wants
to continue and hold on to this pawn
here on e5 but he Spassky decided to go
with the common line around this time
and that was pawn here to f6 Bobby
Fischer plays pawn to d4 and black now
has two options he could bring his
Bishop down here to g4 or he could
decide just to go ahead
take this material here on the for he
ops for bring his Bishop down getting
his lights for a bishop and involved
into the game and now Bobby Fischer he
could take with his own pawn here on e5
exchanged the Queen's on board or kid
not worried about the center of the
board and play pawn to h3 now sometimes
if you play pawn to h3 y can get a
little confused on how to actually
counter the Bishop taking here on f3
because they look at this and say okay
well I have my queen defending this
right here but the queen is also
defending the pawn here on d4 and so
they end up doing something like pawn
taking here on f3 they really weak in
their Kings side of the board but they
don't want to give up this pawn in the
stern of the board they can actually
take here so the Queen can take here on
f3 if we do see the pawn take on d4 then
the rook can swing over to d1 this is
threatening it let's say pawn to c5 now
Queen to b3 this is threatening the
square here on b7 maybe rook to b8 but
then pawn to c3 is really what
solidifies it you can see this pawn
can't take right here if something were
to happen like pawn to d3 this is
completely okay you could just see pawn
up here to c4 now both the rook and the
Queen are attacking it and now there's
no way for black to defend this so this
is the way that white would be able to
come back and get that pawn he was
worried about now in the center of the
board that may not be the setup they
were hoping for but it still allows
white to have that King side structure
like he wants from his pawns but in the
game Bobby Fischer I decided to just go
ahead and take with this pawn here on e5
not worry about all of the scenarios
that just went over the Queen comes down
takes on d1 rook takes on d1 after the
pawn captures the word comes up here to
d3 does not want to be pinned down by
the bishop to the knight right here so
tonight it's free to come up here and
take on e5 if he wants to Bishop to d6
getting that Bishop involved into the
game also defending this pawn here on e5
Knight to d2 and that up here to f6 and
then Knight to sea
so both these Knights are attacking this
pawn in the center of the board so black
is gonna go down in material but decided
to now come in here to e4 gobble up some
material and then Knight to e5 but was a
little bit interested to see you know
why Bobby Fischer took with this night
this night right here on f3 is under
attack I think it makes a lot more sense
for him to go ahead and take right here
on e5 so he doesn't have to worry about
any pinning from this Bishop here on g4
and since there's a lot more pawns to
attack on the Queen side of the board
having most of his material attacking
that makes a lot more sense but in the
game decided to go and play Knight takes
on e5 Bishop takes here on f3 rook or
Knight comes back here to f3 and then
castle on the King side now before we
said that black was probably gonna
castle on the Queen side and that's
exactly what it looked like was gonna
happen but now that most of the
materials off the board specifically the
Queen's black can be a little bit more
aggressive and he doesn't have to worry
about King side safety really can get
his King involved in the center of the
board if he wants to but this is the
quickest way to get his rooks connected
and controlling the center of the board
so with the pawn off here so semi-open
file for this rook on the F file can go
ahead and attack so definitely the most
aggressive way that black can castle and
still attacking his opponents the bishop
comes up here to e3 pawn down here to be
5 to both sides starting to push a
little bit pawn to c4 yes giving up a
pawn rook over here to b8 if you say you
know why won't you just take that pawn
it looks like a free pawn
well it isn't is isn't yes you can take
it right away but White's gonna be able
to get that material back rook here to
d4 immediately gets it back here you
know can't really lose this knight here
as soon as the knight moves then the
pawn is just gonna fall here on c4 in
the game after Bobby Fischer played upon
to c4 but he's fast he's had to bring
his rook over here to b8 supporting that
pawn now by pinch plays rook to c1
supporting his pawn the pawn takes my be
Fischer decides go ahead and bring his
rook up here to d4 he could have taken
material but he recognizes that he can
get that much here
back later in the game there's three
pawns on the C file there's no way for
birdie Spassky to hold on to all that
material so Bobby Fischer just trying to
get his pieces in the position he wants
them not too worried about equalizing in
the pawns right now he can get that
later on
look to e8 centralizing also defending
this night so it doesn't have to move
here Knight back to d2 says hey if you
want to go ahead and exchange our
Knights we can also adding another
attacker on this c4 square black says
yeah I'll go ahead and a take right here
rook comes back here to d2 now rook down
to e4 defending and the square here on
c4 pawn to g3 just wants to make sure
that nothing's gonna happen with this
bishop coming down here and then later
on if there was a back rank mate just
don't want to have to worry about it so
this does open up for the King to come
to g2 which is a safe Square since this
bishop is a dark square bishop bishop
down here to e5 and both the rook and
the bishop now it's hacking this pawn
here on beef - and since the pawn here
on c4 is doing a good job of protecting
the square here on b3 bobby fischer's it
forced to come up here to see - to
protect the square King to f7 starting
to get involved into the game King to g2
rook takes on b2 King up here to f3
attacking and then the rook on e4 pawn
down to c3 King takes pawn takes here
and then the rook takes here on D - so
all of a sudden black is up in material
but as we talked about before too much
material right here for black to hold on
to why it's gonna be able to gobble up
some of that rook back to b5 rook to c2
attacking this pawn here on c6 doesn't
really matter where it moves to you can
see that if it comes to the dark square
both the bishop and the rook are eyeing
down on that Square would it be able to
capture anyway and the King can't come
over fast enough to hold on to that
material so as soon as we see Bishop to
d6 now rook to c6 both sides are again
equal in material rook to a5 and then we
see Bishop to f4 says hey if you want to
exchange off material that's fine with
me rook to a4
check came back here to f3 safe Square
same thing again both sides just going
back and forth after we see the rook
come down here to a2 then the bishop
comes up here exchanging after the rook
takes we are again equal in material
black does now have a passed pawn so if
anyone has an advantage it is but a
Spassky but it is a very very small and
it is it will be difficult for him to
hold on to this advantage plays rook
over here to f2 says yeah I'm not even
gonna worry about too much I don't think
I can take this to the in game so takes
a pawn over here on f2 and Bobby Fischer
takes here on a6 now for the next mini
moves we see a lot of back and forth as
both sides recognizing this is an in
game that they are very familiar with
and it's very difficult for them to
actually win if they had pawns further
up the board it may be an opportunity
where someone could actually do
something but seeing as how their pawns
are only on the 3rd and the 7th rank
respectively and they're really gonna
may have to move maneuvering there look
around the board for the most part both
sides not gonna be able to do too much
and so they're just moving back and
forth seeing if they can come up with
anything but at the end of the day both
sides realizing that there's just no way
for either side to break through seeing
if their opponent will make a mistake in
it the endgame but neither player does
that in this particular game so we go on
a little bit longer but after move a 60
in the game we do see both sides decide
to go ahead and draw they decided
they've they've had to fold repetitions
multiple times and there was just no way
to break through and so they decided to
go ahead and end its I felt like Bobby
Fischer has got to feel pretty good
about this yes you have the white pieces
you would love especially in the
exchange variation to get a win you feel
super comfortable in that opening but
after game 16 still having three full
points ahead of your opponent has to be
a good feeling in a best of 23 series so
hopefully you guys enjoyed Game 16 some
high level chess being played
many people like to always see a victor
in these games but at the end of the day
you don't always get that you just don't
want to see exciting chess and hopefully
you enjoy this one and I will see you
guys in the next video thanks for
watching